the trump campaign has now gone full
mask off and has resorted to tweeting
mugshots of black people
that that's the argument that i punched
my mic there that's the argument
for not voting for joe biden tweeting
mug shots of black people charged with
crimes
these are posts from the verified
twitter account trump war room trump war
room
is an official account run by the trump
2020 campaign team
and they have been tweeting images like
this one that we're putting up on the
screen for our video audience
of a black man charged with violent
crimes remember in our system you are
innocent until proven guilty
they're very quick to talk about that
when it comes to sexual assault
allegations against people like donald
trump
but again they're highlighting charges
against someone
another example that they tweeted out of
a guy named donovan boone
also black charged with crimes and
there's a ton of these
that they've been tweeting out claiming
that these are people that are
free thanks to biden campaign
officials who donated to pay bail
fees so this is both number one
completely obvious and transparent in
terms of
it's just a racist attack to try to hurt
joe biden
and number two and this is the part that
i hate to admit
but really it's an indictment of of of
the people who vote
uh this actually might work i mean i
don't know you know the
the trump war room twitter account is
not necessarily
the place people are going to for news
about the campaign
but the idea that they're floating this
on twitter could lead to
trump talking about it in more detail
and and these are effectively willy
horton ads willie horton ads are still
studied and discussed today if you don't
know what they are back in 1988
um massachusetts governor michael
dukakis who has been a guest on this
program multiple times
was the democratic nominee and was
running against george h.w bush
and george h.w bush started publicizing
with a variety of different so-called
willie horton ads how michael
dukakis let willie horton out
and it was the start of this idea of
democrats
it was more officially codifying the
idea of democrats are going to release
dangerous black people into society
you aren't safe vote for the republican
who will actually keep you safe
this is the exact same thing that we are
seeing from the trump campaign and when
you step back and you know they're
tweeting mug shots of black people i
mean
it's just it's fully brazen at this
point in time
trump's continued use of the term china
virus he's talked about
you know kung flu wuhan flew
all of this stuff back at the beginning
of his campaign
uh mexico is not sending its best it's
sending rapists and criminals and some
who i'm sure are probably good people or
whatever the exact quote was
playing coy with the white supremacists
who have been
activated and coalesced by his campaign
we we've seen it all
time and time again and this is
essentially the same stuff so the the
real practical question for biden harris
is how to deal with this there i i sort
of
exchanged a few messages with democratic
strategists
about if you were running the biden
campaign how do you deal with this
because on the one hand you could say
well
it might actually be effective to
uh try to expose and criticize the fact
that the trump campaign official
campaign people are
using these uh sort of racially tinged
willy horton type strategies
but on the other hand it doesn't really
seem to have worked then what i mean by
that is
trump has been saying xenophobic stuff
and uh
using racist dog whistles for years he
did it in 2015 early
in his campaign into 2016. he's done it
throughout his presidency
and his approval rating stuck right
around the low 40s
and what has actually hurt donald trump
over the last several months
have been three issues it's been
coronavirus handling it's been the
economic situation
as a result of the coronavirus handling
and trump's authoritarian reaction to
the george floyd protest suggesting and
actually sending in
national guard and sort of uh further
militarizing reactions to protests that
are over police brutality to begin with
so
the you know grab them by the you know
what stuff
the um going after trump for the
xenophobia
it really hasn't worked so other
democratic strategists i spoke to said
i would ignore it i would focus on what
has actually hurt donald trump and
in the event two days ago that biden and
harris did
kamala harris focused on an
unnecessarily bad economic
situation coronavirus hit every country
and every country's economy has suffered
but it's worse here because of trump's
failed response
we know that that actually is mattering
to voters
uh hit trump on coronavirus which harris
did
during this first campaign event 48
hours ago
that's another approach from democratic
strategists who are saying the going
after trump for his
crass nature and the language and all
that it's not really worked
focus on what has worked i don't know
what the biden harris team is going to
do
about the birtherism about the willy
horton ads and all of this stuff
but we will follow it and we will see on
august 23rd
we will be at the 15-year anniversary of
the show
huge milestone for us on the one hand
we're heading towards
a million subscribers on youtube and on
the other hand we have this amazing
milestone that is going on so on august
23rd we will be sending out an email to
everybody on our mailing list
with a ungodly is really the best way i
could describe it
membership discount i would love for you
to take part i would love for you to
grab a membership
as we get into this final stretch uh
before the election
and in order to be notified on august
23rd just get on
on my mailing list by signing up at
davidpakman.com
we'll take a quick break we will open up
the phone lines i have some of your
questions i want to answer a little bit
later we've got a great bonus show
it's friday and we have a fantastic
program for you
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video